the visual still gives me goosebumps to
this day because it's pretty much a
nightmare
I think I'm lighting the apartment on
fire the Hobart machine just went full I
cook for a living but surprisingly I
don't have many cooking horror stories
for me personally but I do have one that
involves my mom so this is a couple of
years ago it's Christmas Eve so my whole
family is home for the holidays so
because it's Christmas Eve and we are
hosting a Christmas party the next day
my mom is in the kitchen baking a cake
and she put in all the ingredients and
then she has this big like KitchenAid
mixer which is an awesome tool for any
chef but I guess it can be pretty
dangerous when not used correctly so
there's one lever on one side to unlock
the top so it flips up and then there's
one lever on the other side that turns
it on to mix she went to unlock the
lever to put it up because she wanted to
make sure the mixing attachment was on
correctly but instead she turned the
lover to turn the mixer on while her
hand was inside of the whisk
so it basically turned on and caught her
hand in the mixer and started mixing her
hand which immediately broke broke her
hands which is pretty awful like the
visual still gives me goosebumps to this
day because it's pretty much a nightmare
I guess the thought of what had happened
overwhelmed her so it made her
lightheaded and passed out but without
having known that we were just so
confused at what had happened but yeah
that is the story of our Christmas cake
disaster so I was playing hooky from
work I remember I had called out because
I think I was like a little hungover and
I decided that today was the day I was
gonna cook I had just moved into an
apartment in Manhattan with my two
roommates and I was in the kitchen and I
had put on the oven to preheat it and I
went away to go take a shower or
something I think I was making like
cheese toast but I never really had
turned on the oven in this apartment
before and I went into the shower when I
got out of the shower billows of smoke
were everywhere so I went to go open up
the oven and there was nothing in the
oven so then I got even more freaked out
that there was all the smoke coming out
and I had no idea what it was from then
I opened up the broiler and saw that my
roommates store their oven mitts in
there and I open it up and it's just
three mitts just in flames and then now
with the smoke is everywhere the flames
are everywhere it's so I call my super
crying and panicking and I was like I
think I'm lighting the apartment on fire
and the guy that picked up the phone was
the maintenance guy and he didn't really
speak English and I know Spanish but in
this particular moment in time
I lost all ability to know any words in
Spanish and I just started screaming
help and then all I could get out of me
was Fuego and so I started screaming
help
Wego for about five minutes straight and
then I heard him come my door and the
maintenance guy came in and was like
looking at me like holy crap what do we
do so that was like kind of made it
worse for me I still had no relief
because even though another person was
joining me they realized how terrible it
was that I'd got myself into so what
happened was we wind up turning off the
oven cuz I didn't turn it off in this
entire time because I was freaking out
so much so we turned up the oven he
brought in like two big industrial fans
to try to make the apartment not smell
like burnt fabric but I'm pretty sure
the smell lingered for like the
following month afterwards were like our
brand-new Manhattan apartment just
because I decided to make sure
dose on my day off yeah I used to have a
cooking class in high school and I was
excited to take the class because I
wanted to be a chef when I want to learn
as much as I can and one particular day
we were making a bunch of food for a
banquet and I was making focaccia bread
for 300 people and I was paired with
this girl named Crystal who didn't want
to cook for the rest of her life she was
there because it was easy for her we had
this huge Hobart mixer to put the
focaccia dough ingredients into so
inside there was flour water salt some
herbs and we were about to mix the batch
together in the huge Hobart mixer and I
was like oh Krystal like wait one second
I have to go grab a spatula to like
clean down all the sides and I don't
know if she didn't hear me or you know
didn't get what I was talking about but
as I was walking away I heard the of the
machine being turned on and I was like
oh I was like running back I was like no
because she didn't just choose like the
first level or the second level where it
would have probably like worked fine she
went all the way to the top and I just
hear like look to keep the ku-ku-ku-ku I
think an explosion is an understatement
the hobart machine just went full and
like all the content inside of the
Hobart mixer exploded into the air it
was on her from like head-to-toe it went
all over me it went all over the tables
on the walls it even went on the ceiling
and everyone in the entire room stopped
what they were doing then just like
stared at us like their mouths were like
all the kids were like shocked in the
past our chef instructor was very upset
so crystal and I had to stay after class
until the entire kitchen was clean I had
to like stand on tables with a brush and
like scrub the ceiling no joke
crystal let's just say she's not a chef
[Music]